hi steve how are you
i'm doing good what you didn't know when
you signed on to direct to bond was you
were going to do a thousand interviews
over five days
no i had a feeling we're going to do a
pretty big press tour that's always the
uh the last little the last step in the
process of making something
uh listen i got a lot of questions for
you and i want to start with
congratulations you had me on the edge
of my seat for like
i don't know 95 of this movie um but i
like asking uh a curveball at the
beginning uh i am a huge stanley kubrick
fan and i read that you might be the one
to finally bring napoleon to life i just
have to ask you is that true
i've been working on that now for i want
to say four or five years maybe longer
uh so um yeah i'm definitely you know
involved in that we're still we've got
all the scripts now the episodes and
we're you know getting ready to to see
where the next stage is on it so it's
happening
i mean i have so many follow-ups um i'm
just going to leave it there and say i
really hope you're the one who can bring
it to life because he spent so much time
developing that and i mean all the way
he spent a lot of time in his library
and uh and at the house at st albans
with you know with christiana's wife and
jan his brother in law it's uh it's
pretty awesome to just even be in the
presence of of kubrick's uh
library
um so jumping into bond uh
i would imagine you thought like it
might go a certain i guess what i'm
curious about is what surprised you
about making a film of this scale and
scope um that maybe you weren't
expecting going in
um it's hard to say in hindsight now i
think you know you imagine these bond
films already to be pretty massive
endeavors i think it's hard to
understand
how much of it is a family-run endeavor
though you know from from uh barbara
broccoli and michael g wilson they
they've been doing this together for
decades now and they are they remain uh
autonomous from the studios even though
they part partner with them to to
finance these things they
they hold the keys you know so
it's um
it's it's it's like a very
well oiled
massive
you know
you know
film endeavor but also a mom-and-pop
operation
sure uh um was it ever going to be
called something else besides no time to
die or did this title was this always
the title
i i mean obviously beginning we didn't
know the title that's why you know all
of our slates say b25 but um you know i
think they came up with it about halfway
in like barbara kind of like was always
pitching these ideas and we'd pitch
things and go back to like some flaming
short stories or filming kind of chapter
headings and we're just trying to find
something that worked for this and then
i don't know who actually came up with
it the other day it wasn't me i can't i
can't claim credit for it
uh i thought that you and linus did such
a great job collaborating on this film
how did you end up picking linus to
shoot it
i it's funny on maniac uh emma stone
said you've got to meet linus he's he's
amazing you're going to love him and i
i'd seen some of damian's films some of
the lina says projects with david
russell but it was really you know
seeing first man and seeing what they
did in first man that i thought was just
amazing craft work amazing
cinematography and just a really you
know engaging film so that that was for
me the big motivation seeing that film
maybe next time i'll pronounce his name
correctly i'm just throwing that out
there um you shot a lot of this in imax
was there ever any talk of even shooting
more in imax than you did or was the 40
or 50 minutes that you did already too
much
uh i would have shot the whole thing in
imx i loved it i really did and uh i
think one of the trickier things imax is
that there's only six cameras really so
once nolan started using tenant he
pretty much you know
he took all of
them he does he does have ownership over
everything when it comes to that stuff
yeah yeah
um so this is the longest bond movie uh
to date and i'm curious did you have a
like a longer cut that you like you know
what i mean like how long was your
director's cut if you will of the film
it wasn't that much longer uh i had an
assembly of the film 10 days after
wrapping that was just under three hours
so over the course of the next like 12
weeks we trimmed it down another 17
minutes tighten things maybe swapped out
some takes but that was it
oh wow um did you end up with like any
deleted scenes or was it more like
taking the air out of the room in
certain sequences
there was
mainly just taking the out of the room
and tightening you know dropping lines
dialogue uh there was a couple sort of
action sequences we might have truncated
just a little bit
but um and some connective tissue as
well you know you know getting from
point a to point b and that's where most
of tightening took place
do you believe that fans will ever see
like the the stuff you cut out or do you
do you believe in the whole once it's
out of the movie it's never going to be
seen
it's funny you know if you think about
the early 2000s and all those kind of
deleted scenes extras that you saw on
dvds you know i'd watch them and always
be like oh i'm glad they didn't put that
in
you know
so i likewise i think if they ever did
dvd extras i would i would say
personally i think if a scene was
deleted there's probably a reason it was
deleted
sure unless we're talking about the
kingdom of heaven director's cut in
which case it's a masterpiece and people
need to see it just bringing up ridley
scott oh really
yeah no oh my god someone told me
there's like a four-hour version
or a five-hour version of magnolia and
i i actually would really love to see
the five hour version of magnolia
i would pay someone big money to see
that version of the movie i would
i would but i'm telling you if you
haven't seen the extended cut of kingdom
of heaven it's like my favorite film of
that year it's 40 something minutes of
extra footage and it completely changes
the film that that's i'll look for it
um i strongly recommend it so um i think
this is the issue with contemporary
filmmaking is that you know studio is
driven by sort of i think i can't say
why they think all the time but the kind
of the runtime issue that goes for
television too
driven by you know
the kind of mediocre or the median line
of content you know that keeps people's
eyes engaged in projects drives even
uh the length the running time of films
that shouldn't be driven by that by that
tenant and it's like you know david lean
made incredible films that were four or
five hours long and i just wish i wish a
story can just be the length it needs to
be and not try to fit into the box just
so you know just just in case you know
people are afraid they won't pay
attention
yeah listen i yeah we could have a whole
conversation on this and i believe me i
i
uh yes i fully agree with what you're
saying um so i love the warner in the
movie and i'm just curious you've done
obviously some really cool wonders in
the past um did you have a lot of talk
about did you try to do even more in
this movie or is even just doing do you
know what i mean like what because it's
challenging to film these and with the
time and the budget and everything could
you i guess could you talk about it
yeah i've i've avoided talking about it
when people have asked me if there's if
we can expect something like that in
this film because i'd rather you know
people watch the film without any
expectation of a kind of craft piece
somewhere in the middle because i always
feel like that disengages the suspense
of the suspension of disbelief that
you're just striving for the entire time
but it in terms of
execution and trying to find ways to do
this you know
it's really interesting like even in
matera there's a few shots that last
longer than they normally would have
like daniel is a perfectionist so
in his punch-up scenes he wants to make
sure every punch every dodge every block
is pitch perfect and you know when you
if you ever watch musicians make a song
they'll go in and cut in sometimes note
for note for note and i think daniel
likes to kind of get the punches and the
cuts and like just have have cuts there
so you can do line the perfect punch and
i wanted to do a few things where we
have like three or four combos in a shop
before we cut and you know for someone
who wants to perform at that level
that's that's a lot of pressure
i remember him being like i don't know i
feel like we need to cut i think we
should have some cuts for safety you
know i'm like no no trust me we got this
and like the scene where he takes uh the
henchman and matera and ends up you know
not you know wrapping the laundry cable
on his eye and his head and then
knocking him out is just one shot and
you don't notice it when you're watching
it because there's no reason that there
should be a cut there you know just
you're just watching action unfold and
hopefully the execution isn't calling
attention to itself so that's i think
that's always the the
the aim right is to shoot in a way that
the edits are only there as necessary in
other words other ways otherwise the the
movie is just unfolding uh organically
yeah it makes me crazy when i watch an
action sequence that has 30 cuts in
three seconds it
it just me and that's the reason why i
you know i thought you did such a great
job with this did you have a good enough
experience making this film that you'd
be you know if barbara calls you back
and says hey
would you be willing to go back because
making the bond movie i don't think
people realize it's a huge time
commitment of your life
yeah i mean i gave
20 months
more than that
of
seven day a week you know like
16 to 18 hour long days
uh and and didn't see anyone didn't go
home you know and then lockdown happened
and 18 months of that so it's like i
feel like i'm just emerging into the
world again and and to say like oh yeah
i'll do that again right away would be
uh i wouldn't be sincere to like my my
sort of creative and also just life
aspirations
uh but i really did love the experience
and i think if it was the right time and
the right idea for it uh i could
definitely be tempted to come back i
need you to make napoleon first on that
note i got to stop and say seriously man
congrats and as a fan of your work i'm
glad i got to talk to you
oh thank you man it was a pleasure we
should we'll have a run in time
conversation on a later date dude you
name the time and day and i will do it
it's for real and watch kingdom of
heaven the director's cut uh have a
great day thank you i'll look for it
i'll look forward
you